كثيرا ما يصاب الانسان بالملل الذي قد
يراه الكثيرون انه قاتل واكثر خطوره من
امراض صعبه لكن دراسه فرنسيه تفتح الباب
عالم اسرائيل امام فوائد الملل الدراسه
الجديده سندت لمعاشه الفرنسيون الفتره
العزل الصحي عقب تفشيكونا حين التزم
الجميع بيوتهم وستلقلق من الوباء ما سرب
الملل لقلوبها لكن وبحسب طبيب فرنسي
باتريك ليمون فان الامر لم يكن كذلك حيث
اثبت التجارب وجود جوانب جيده للملل فهو
الذي اجبر العقول عن الابداع وطرق ابواب
جديده غير معلوفه على حد تعبيره الطبيب
الفرنسيه يرى ان العقل حين يشعر بالملل
يظهر وكانه سيطير وهنا تنفتح الفجوات بين
دماغ الايمن والايسر لتزيده وميض العبقريه
[موسيقى]
اه في الحقيقه هذه دراسه ما هي جديده هذه
الدراسه جدا قديمه بس الانسان صار بعيد عن
الدراسات صار بعيد عن التطلع في الامور دي
يعني في الحقيقه واحنا صغار ما كان في شيء
اسمه الانسان
يعمل اشياء حتى لو كان فيها مشاغبه بس
بس حبيبتك هيطلع باسراء يعني كنا جربنا
اوقات الملل هالايام الحجر الصحي وايام
كورونا كيف يمكن تنظيف الملل للابداع بدل
ما يتحول الى اكتئاب مضر لصاحب
اه شوفي هو احيانا الانسان تيجي له الصحوه
وفي ناس لا
اذا انا افضى اغير من الملل لحاجه يعني
يعني اخلي حياتي يكون شكلها مختلف فانا
اللي لازم اطلع انا الي لازم اقوم وادور
وابحث عن شيء انا ارغب فيه انا انا فرضا
في ايام كرونه اكيد ما في احد ما عمل ايام
كرونه لكن
قعدت اطلع وقعدت ادرس وقعدت عرفت كيف كان
في اشخاص كتير حوالي برده نفس الحاجه
فالانسان هو اللي فاعل الشيء
[موسيقى]
امال ممكن ابداع وفي واحد ثاني ممكن يوديك
سكه غلط او افكار جنونيه افكار شيطانيه
الكلام ده كله على حسب العقل في الاول وفي
الاخر يعني بعد لما يكون قاعد لوحده بتحس
ان في كده
انا اكتشفت حاجات كثير بسبب الملل او
الفضاء واحد يكون عنده موهبه الرسم فيطلع
الملل بتاعه دوت في الرسمه يطلع اي حاجه
في الرسم بس مش برده مش في كل الاوقات
يعني الناس ممكن يخليني مثلا افكر في اللي
انا باعمله مختلفه او كده ولكن مثلا لو
حاجه انا اصلا ما بحبهاش من الاول او يعمل
لي عقده نفسيه ممكن لا يبقى خليني
اكثر ما انا اصلا مخنوق من حاجه يعني
[موسيقى]